the human brain it's one of the most
powerful machines around simulating a
single second of its activity needs
almost 85,000 processes the brain is a
multi scale very complex entity and we
have to we have to look at all the
different levels of detail to understand
there's still so much we don't know like
how to fix the brains of dementia
patients how to harness our subconscious
and why we dream human brain project is
a ten year effort to advance our
understanding of the human brain and to
develop new treatments for medicine and
new technologies based on the brain we
are generating more and more data about
the brain in laboratories all around the
world but until we bring that data
together and put it see how the pieces
fit together we won't have a coherent
picture of how the brain actually
functions scientists from across Europe
are using decades of research already
done on brain function to build a
working model of the brain and simulated
on a supercomputer an enormous task
they've got ten years and more than two
billion dollars to try to make it happen
and the long term towards the end of the
project our goal is to have an exascale
supercomputer so this is an
extraordinarily fast supercomputer that
would be capable of running a simulation
of the human brain at the level of
individual cells there's one problem
the technology it doesn't exist yet
if scientists are going to simulate the
brain they're going to need a computer
that's 35 times faster than today's
supercomputer that's as powerful as 100
million laptops with the project set to
last 10 years it may be a while until we
start to see results until then it's
bound to cause a few headaches